Hello,
every body,
just before we get started into this one today,
I do want to say that a lot of Japanese words,
if I scrub the pronunciations,
I did my best.
Have a good at me in the comments below if you want that spot there for
me and motive muscle sheet was the greatest swordsman you rather come out of a
nation of great swordsman and that would of course in Japan.
His story which has become the basis for countless flying swords and an oriental
movies is one of raw courage,
unbridled ambition,
and unparalleled mindfulness in one on one combat.
He defeated 16 opponents,
yet his greatest legacy is a seminal work.
The book of five rings,
which is still poor,
dover by military tacticians and mindfulness,
enthusiastic for 150 years after it was written.
In this week's biographics,
we reveal the man that was Masashi
there as much uncertainty over the details and dates pertaining to the life of
Masashi.
What follows is based primarily on his own account,
as recorded in the book of five rings,
me and massage Masashi was born in the spring of 15,
84 in the village of Mia Moto in the Yoshino districts of the Masaka province in
Japan.
He was born into an ability with his mother who died giving birth to him being
the daughter of a minor local chief Tang.
His father Mooney was a warrior in the Shin Man Clan who had become an experts
in the fighting arts.
He was especially adept at Jujitsu swordsmanship and the use of the guitar.
An iron rod with forklift protrusions when he was in his thirties.
Mooney had been invited to the capital of Kyoto to deal with another highly
regarded warrior in the presence of the Shogun Mooney beat the man in two out of
three bouts.
The victory established and massage his father as he whole show,
which means without equal in Japan,
really was intense on teaching his son everything that he knew about the
fighting arts.
Although Misashi it was a quick learner.
He had a stubborn streak that sort of constantly clashing with his father.
While everyone else treated me with the utmost respect and reverence,
Misashi would often talk back and criticize his father.
This resulted in a volatile relationship which often culminated in violence.
On one occasion,
Muni took a knife and threw it at his son was actually managed to dodge the
weapon,
which buried itself in the wall beside him,
but the fathers aren't get it was not over.
He,
through the seven year old boy out of the house,
essentially disowning him was actually crossed,
become a soccer pass to the province of Hiroshima where he traveled to the small
village of [inaudible].
Here he was taken in by his uncle,
dearin.
Dearin has once been a warrior,
but he had long ago renounced the fighting arts,
becoming a Buddhist monk and is living a life of study and meditation.
He raised Misashi at is small Buddhist temples,
sat on the edge of the village here,
the coin lands to read and to write as well as to meditate and develop the
spirituality,
massaging his real passion.
However,
lay with a martial arts.
He spends countless hours alone in the woods,
sparring against the unforgiving trunks of pine trees.
His anger at his being released as he builds upon the skills that had been
instilled by that great worry out and his work for book of five rings.
Misashi recorded that his first real fight occurred when he was 13 years of age.
He related that to passing warrior by the name of Mickey High.
I put a sign up along the Ohio River,
challenging any local swordsman to a deal.
The bolds and impetus Misashi took up the challenge,
writing his name on the sign,
key high,
considered the challenge and joke,
but accepted any way intent on teaching the young upstart or lesson ms dot
Ashley's Uncle Doren with sharks.
When he heard what his nephew had done on the day of the challenge,
she went to head of the buyer and attempted to beg us off while he was eating
with key high misashi challenged his opponents with a six foot quarter staff.
He caught off guard,
clubbing him to the ground,
and then striking him between the eyes with a succession of blows.
He then beat him to death.
Three years later,
Masashi left Heroku and set off to make his way in the world.
He traveled along the sand Yoda,
the old high road scouting the northern shore of the inland sea to the streets
of Shem on Saqib.
From that,
he ferried across the waters to the port of [inaudible] and then onto knack at
Psu.
This was the castle town,
whereas father now lives moody had entered into the service of the master of
Nicodemus,
you causal.
The teenager arrived to find his father's on me.
We're in the midst of a campaign,
just,
uh,
do the islands of shoe and wage war on the western provinces was actually,
was recruited into the force and soon found himself fighting alongside his
father.
It was his first taste of war.
The campaign proved to be a great success with two provinces being brought onto
the dominion of your Shitaka.
Following the campaign with Sashi,
his aging father retired from active duty moving to the nearby port of kids.
Suki.
Yes,
as the father exited from the wells of mortal Kombat of a sudden it was just
getting started.
That campaign,
it had wet his appetite and he was eager for more in terms of becoming a great
warrior or swordsmen like his father.
He set out a path forward.
He needed to perfect the art of swordsmanship,
seek out and defeat other masters and then found his own school of swordsman
ship.
Never one to think small.
Misashi had set his sights on the most prestigious school of swordsmanship in
the realm the famous Yoshioka clowning in Kyoto.
He knew that if he could fully defeat even one member of this plan,
he would put himself on the fast track to recognition as a master swordsman,
so without saying a word to his father,
he rose early one morning,
collected his few belongings and set out to claim his destiny.
He bought it his way onto a small merchant vessel to the port of Sakaki.
From there,
he sat on foot ticket Jojo and sought out the Yoshioka can.
He threw down his challenge,
which was easily accepted by their top swordsman.
St Jerome.
The jewel would take place on the grounds of the temple.
What do you really have to the venue?
Masashi leapt upon his opponent without wanting,
just as he had done in his first deal and felled see jerry with a single blow
from his October.
The fight was over before it had even properly began.
The shock defeat of their top swordsmen rocked the Yoshioka clan,
so Jira is brother denture.
Chiro was incensed that the manner in which the young upstart from the south had
attacked his brother when he was unprepared.
He challenged him it to a second challenge on the very spot where the first it
occurred.
This time there was the Yoshioka swordsmen who charged first attempting to
strike a fatal blow with this five foot Bako massage.
She managed to wrestle the weapon away from denture cheery,
using it to beat his opponent to death.
The Yoshioka had now been best dish twice in short order,
and this was too much for that honor to bath.
They decided that Misashi had to be killed.
They devised a plan to ambush him in the woods outside of the hostel where he
was staying more than 100 Yoshioka students armed with sticks,
bows and arrows gathered under the leadership of denture.
His son,
his name was Matt Cheerio,
and he came up against Misashi unperturbed.
Masashi rushed,
straightforward matter,
Shakira,
killing him in front of the others.
Overall,
the Yoshioka fell back,
allowing Misashi to slip away,
having established his supremacy blank,
decimating the most highly respected warrior clan in the land.
Misashi returns to Kyoto in the space of a few days.
He had brought down a school of swordsmanship that had reigned supreme for over
a century still.
He knew that he had a lot to learn in order to become the greatest warrior in
the nation from Kyoto.
He traveled to the temple of Nahrep.
Here he founds a line of warrior monks who were experts in the art of fighting
with the of the temple master was fascinated with massage.
She's ability to find with two swords at once.
Kinda test is find a student against the newcomer.
He arranged for two belts with a monk named aqua zone.
In neither of these fights was the lawns are able to gain the upper hand over
Masashi leaving,
Nara and the south.
He traveled to each city that was teeming with accomplished swordsmen.
Many of these swordsmen had forged that talents on the field of battle here.
Masashi opened his own Dojo,
one of hundreds in the city news,
quickly spread of his unique style and he soon was being flooded with students.
One of them was Mazuma cuts scenario,
well respected and battle hardened warrior.
The fame of massages Dojo.
It's spread reaching all the way to ido castle and the shogun himself.
He was invited to teach that,
but declines when he realized that he would be subject to a member if he hated
Yag.
You can after teaching an ido for seven years,
but it's actually decided to return to could Suki,
the town of his father.
The aging Mooney had set up his own Dojo and was eager to pass it on to his son
before he arrived back in.
Could Suki,
however Musashi wants to fight one more challenge at his journey home,
brought him to the small islands of fun,
Ashima in the streets of Shamona.
Second,
it was here that he was challenged by a famed warrior by the name of [inaudible]
Congero.
This was a man so fierce that he understands the Monica Demon of the western
provinces.
He was a master [inaudible].
The greatest Japanese sword.
Legend tells us that massage,
she's only weapon,
was a bucket or a wooden sword that he had carved from an owner of the boat that
had brought him to the islands.
With this,
he managed to subdue and kills the Saki.
We don't immediately jumped into his boat and rode out to see in order to get
away from Susaki is enraged followers.
Misashi now completed his journey to Suku where he began teaching at his
father's Dojo for three years.
He lived in,
worked in a small seaside village.
During this time,
his fractured relationship with his father had got my better with the old man
criticizing his son's marsh inability at every opportunity.
When Mooney died at the age of 85,
Masashi was more relieved than saddened.
Shortly after his father's passing,
Misashi received a letter from his former students,
Missou new cut scenario.
War had broken out between the grades.
Clans have Tagawa,
arends,
Toya,
Tony got scenario was about to take pause in the seed zone,
the Tokugawa site,
along with his eldest son,
who was just 16 years old.
Cotsen already requested the Musashi serve as part of a special escort of 10
mounted warriors for his son.
The 30 year olds Misashi Solvis as his opportunity to jump back into the thick
of combat.
He sets off from Turkey to the port of Sakaki.
He was determined to be the protector in battle of the young son if his beloved
students,
he met up with [inaudible] forces writing at the head of 4,000 men as they
advanced on a soccer and then on to Kakadu or hamlet.
It's made up of a few farms stretching along the southern bank of the Yamamoto
River just a few miles down stream.
A lodge enemy force had gathered that night.
However,
cats scenarios,
Ami managed to surrounds the Toyotomi forces.
The attack was ordered at 10:00 PM.
The hour of the snake and the Toyotomi were sent reeling.
They fled across the river.
I will need to be chased down by cat scenarios.
Men Misashi was in the lead wielding his favorite weapon.
The bulk tall records tell us that he stood on the heights of a bridge sending
one enemy warrior after another,
flying with the deadly blows of his trusted blocked all the Osaka Windsor in
summer campaigns in which the Tokugawa were victorious,
but an ends to the resistance of Japan's western warlords.
The culmination of the hostilities was the siege of a soccer castle.
It was the largest vessel in which Masashi would ever take part with many
thousands of worry is being slaughtered on both sides.
Among those of his comrades to fall was Naca Galwass.
She amount of keep.
It was stricken down.
His men had stormed the southern gate of the castle.
The man had three sons who traveled with the army.
The two older boys took part in the siege,
but the youngest was just 11 with the death of his father.
The young man now needed a guardian
massaging,
took the boy Minuka Suki under his wing,
adopting him as his son and set off with the castle town of him a.
from there,
they want zero.
Who were his stepmother,
lived for the next two years.
He lived here caring for his elderly stepmother while also providing for his new
son many hours each day with spence imparting to nick and a Suki,
the fighting skills that he himself had learned as a young boy from his own
father.
This tranquil existence was interrupted when news reached the village of heroes
that Akita mood some Masa,
the current Lord of him.
A castle was going to move.
The new Lord was going to be a Honda.
Tomasa.
Masa Masashi saw this change in leadership as an opportunity for his adopted son
during the storming,
a soccer castle Tadamasa had been in command if the second eastern phonics
directly behind the troops of cap scenario where Masashi with stations.
He has therefore seen Musashi and action in the heat of battle.
Ms Dot Aldrete requested that his son,
mid Masa be given duty in the Lord's household,
not that Masa agreed as the boy was made a page to his own son to Tokyo.
At the same time,
Sasha was hired by the neighboring demio August Sowell,
Tarzan,
yet he was appointed as an advisor to the magistrate in charge of the
construction of a huge building projects the construction of the Kashi Castle.
This was followed by the planning of the town,
if it may.
Misashi was also in charge of the castle gardens and oversaw the construction of
a tea house miniature mountains into miniature lake.
He proved to have a meticulous eye for detail and was obsessive in getting every
tree shrub and stone placed just right.
The years that he spent to Kashi were the happiest of massages,
life,
as well as planning out the landscaping and tending to the gardens.
He instructed his retainers in the art of fighting with two swords.
He also enjoyed hearing of these successes of his son who grew in favor in the
house of Tata Masa.
In the spring of [inaudible] 16,
26 loads had a Tokyo was struck down with tuberculosis being forced to keep us
quarters that he may castle after a three month struggle with a disease.
He died at 1:30.
We're so actually knew all too well what this meant for his son as the key
retainer.
If the stricken Lord Makinos Suki was customarily bounced to commit ritual
suicide by December ailments,
Makina Suki is death left,
a deep emotional scar on Masashi from which he would never fully recover for
months.
He shunned or company retreating to the forest to commune with nature and tried
to come to terms with his great loss almost exactly a year after Makina souk is
deaf massage.
She adopted a second son,
a boy named Laurie,
who was the second son of tomorrow,
is a Mitsui,
a Samurai,
and the service of the Lord of Mickey Castle.
When their costs had been overthrown by the Tagawa army,
hit some.
Mitsui took up the life of a poor farmer.
When he died,
his youngest son,
Lori,
became an orphan.
Masashi took it in and arranged for him to enter the service of Lord Tanzania.
The boy would eventually attained the rank of senior retainer stations,
only southern islands of can you shoe Misashi moved to be closer to the boy and
spent the last 20 years of his life on the islands.
Miss Ashley built a large Dojo on the islands and soon had a huge following,
all eager to learn from the great master,
even though located on a remote islands,
far from the main centers.
Many martial arts masters visited his Dojo to experience the art of fighting
with two swords.
The aging the associate was respected and admired as a great martial arts
grandmaster still,
he was,
as he had always been an outsider.
He did not agree with himself as was expected.
He left his hair grow long and unkempt.
He also sell them bathed and refused to wear the traditional attire of a
swordsman.
Of that time,
in his waning years,
even abandoned his two swords,
preferring to carry and using nothing more than a five foot wooden staff in
early at 16,
38 and armed revolt broke out in the province of.
He's in the rebellion was made up of Christians led by 17 year old Ama Coosa
Shiro.
They numbered more than 20,000 men that has gone to themselves.
The long abandoned hardcastle Lord is how does the employer have massage.
She's adopted.
Son engaged the aging master to escort his 23 year old son to the battlefields
along with 8,000 men,
Misashi state at the boys' side,
throughout the entire siege when the defenders in selling,
because all three boulders down from the walls,
he leapt in front of the Lord source and fended them off with his staff.
Misashi hadn't been back from the rebellion for long when he was approaching,
take up a position in the household of the Dynamo of one of the largest fiefs in
the country.
This was Hosokawa Tata,
Toshi.
He wanted Misashi to relocate,
to come emoto and instruct his retainers in the art of fighting with two sorts.
This ultimate accepted,
arriving and Kumomoto in September of 16,
40,
he was given a comfortable mentioned on the northeastern side of the castle
grounds.
Massage,
took to spending much time in the mountains of it washow where he would while
away the hours in meditation and contemplation,
he found a cave which afforded him perfect solitude.
It was here that he began to put his thoughts to paper in the early spring of
16,
45.
He completed the first draft of the work that would make him a mortal down
through the ages,
the Gorran no show or book of five rings.
The book had taken five seasons to complete each one and seeing the completion
of one long scroll.
He named them for scrolls of earth,
fire,
water,
wind,
and heaven.
Shortly after the completion of his great work massage,
she's health took a turn for the worse.
Within a month,
he was no longer able to teach.
He withdrew to his house outside the castle walls.
Feeling is life adding a way.
He summoned his chief retainer and handed in the garden,
no show.
Having passed on his legacy,
he then closed his eyes and allowed the life to drain from his body.
It was June the 13th,
16,
40th five,
shortly after his death,
a stone memorial to be known as mounds Masashi was directed not far from his
home and Keto for centuries thereafter,
passes by with dismounted from their horses to pay homage to the greatest
swordsmen that Japan which effort produce.
So I really hope you found this video interesting.
If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below and do not forget to subscribe for
brand new videos just like this every Monday and Thursday.
Also check out some of our videos from the archive that over there on the right.
If you enjoyed this video,
you'll enjoy some of those and as always,
thank you for watching.